The question that me
and my co-founder Max,
Max Deutsch, ask ourselves was
what type of life do we want to live?
Right?
And for us, the answer is we just want
to spend time
learning and creating, right?
Valentin Perez, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 minute leaders.
How are you?
Thank you, Michael.
I'm doing great.
How about you?
I'm doing fantastic.
Thank you so much for joining me
and being so generous with your time.
You're calling from Los Angeles
and you're actually living
with Cliff Weitzman
who I believe was one
of the first guests on the show
which is pretty, pretty cool.
Amazing, yeah. We're super cool friend.
So, from Mexico,
went to Brown University,
co-president of the entrepreneurship
program there,
got into startups,
worked in quite a few places,
one of them as a
software engineering intern at Snapchat,
which I'd love to hear
what that experience is all about.
But now, most recently,
you are the CEO
and co-founder of Monthly,
an online education platform
focusing on month courses, right?
Did I get that right?
Yeah.
The co-founder of Monthly,
and we do one month
hands-on online classes
taught by big creators and artists.
Amazing. Amazing.
So, you know Valentin,
before we get into really
in the depth of monthly
and what you're doing there,
I'd love to go back a little bit
and talk about
your entrepreneurial journey
and sort of the steps leading up
to your endeavor right now.
So, when would you consider
you started as an entrepreneur?
Oh, I would say since,
like ever since I can remember.
I was just always
with the entrepreneurial mindset
and I think it's because of the way
that I grew up and the way that
my parents raised me,
like one of the earliest questions
that I always remember
my dad asking myself is,
would you rather be the
tail of a lion or the head of a mouse?
And I would always ironically answer
the head of a lion.
But for him, he was always like
asking that question
kind of rhetorically,
that it's better to be
the head of a mouse,
even if the small thing.
You be the entrepreneur,
the person like leading
or having your own
charge of your own destiny
than being the tail
of a bigger organization
or some other group.
So, ever since I was a kid,
I was always working on projects,
selling things,
like building stuff,
you know, websites, apps, robots,
selling sushi across my neighborhood,
like everything that you can imagine.
Yeah.
So, what was the motivation for it?
Sorry?
What was the motivation
for doing all those projects?
Was it simply to make money
were some people sell lemonade
in a lemonade stand
or you did the other
entrepreneur projects?
Or was there other reasons
why you went about them?
Yeah, I mean,
I think when I was a kid,
it was mostly fun.
It was just like
I was just having fun playing around,
that's what I found fun, fulfilling.
And then it was also about
sort of getting into creating value
and helping other people, right?
So, I see entrepreneurship is just
literally the way
like you're creating value
and you're helping improve
other people's lives.
And then I think there is like,
a fun, play, creating value,
but a big part of it for me, too,
is curiosity and like
learning new things
and understanding
new parts of the world
and that maybe as experimenting.
I think some other motivators for me
are love, just coming,
like giving love, receiving love.
Gratefulness, always being
grateful about what I have
and making the most out of the
opportunities and chances
that I have.
And I think that creating value
goes with the desire to be useful.
Yeah, it's just creating value,
love, gratefulness, curiosity, play, fun.
Right.
So, you're talking about
creating value, love, curiosity.
If I recall correctly,
one of the things that you also did
is send a newsletter
with a bunch of gifts.
Right?
Talk to me a little bit
about that newsletter.
Yeah, so.
One thing I love doing
is curating things.
So, ever since I was a kid,
I had a list of my favorite quotes,
or like a list
of my favorite articles.
And I always just
stored all these things.
And I love finding the gems
in the Internet of, like,
what are the best videos,
what are the best articles,
what are the best ideas,
what are the best books.
And I just like have
a lot of fun doing this.
And then, part of that is like
I also joined a lot of newsletters.
Like I spend a lot of time
just learning things online
and part of that was newsletters.
And then I felt, you know,
I'm storing all these things
thinking to myself,
why don't I just share all of these
that I've accumulated,
all of these amazing
gems, articles, ideas,
habits, etcetera, and just share
them with my friends and family.
So I just, you know, as an experiment
I posted like,
hey, would anyone be interested?
And then I got like
hundreds of messages and comments
of people that wanted to
get this newsletter
and I just started sending it.
And the premise was, you know,
mouth-watering articles
like juicy books.
Yeah. It's like,
provoke [--] pictures.
So, it was like a cross,
like many different types of media,
all of them
the best things that I can find.
And it wasn't only
things that I found throughout the week.
It was like over the years
and the whole lifetime of like
creating all these things.
Right?
So, I focused on quality over recency.
And I did sprinkle a bit of recency
because part of my newsletter
was also sending
my favorite songs
and new artist that I was finding.
I also just love
making Spotify plus, for example.
And yeah,
it was like part of the newsletter.
And it actually was
extremely fun and rewarding
because it was a way
to keep in touch
with a ton of friends
and family and people.
I only have to write this email once
and send it once a week and it gets
to like hundreds of people.
And then if anyone,
if they're interested,
they can reply or not.
But I always had, like,
people sharing back more thoughts,
more ideas,
like just having a conversation.
There was just absolute blast.
I think that's
there's so much ingenuity in that.
I took inspiration from
a great friend of mine, Drew Bent.
I don't know if you got to meet him,
but he's a Knight-Hennessy scholar
at Stanford.
And he went to MIT launch with me.
And he send out this year-end review
Drew's Year-End Review
as a one time
once a year newsletter.
And I started adopting that,
doing it more quarterly or biannually.
And it was amazing
to see how with one email
I can reach hundreds of people.
And all of a sudden
you get their responses
and you're invigorating
these connections.
And I think that
it's such a wonderful technique
to get in touch with people.
I'm obviously enjoying meeting new people
and maintaining relationships
through a show like this.
So, I'm definitely in favor
of all of these different endeavors.
Talk to me a little bit about
entrepreneurship at Brown University.
What does it mean to be
an American college student in America?
You're from Mexico
but you're studying college in America.
And you're leading
an entrepreneurship experience
also for other students.
What was that about?
Yeah, so for me,
I just, I knew
that I wanted to get involved
with the entrepreneurship scene
even before I got into Brown.
Once I got to Brown, like,
that was like the first thing that I did.
I joined the hackathon
and the hackathon organizing team
because I went to the hackathon
as a high schooler before Brown.
And so,
I knew I want to be a part of that.
And when I got to Brown, like,
I knew that I wanted to continue working
on my own entrepreneurial projects.
But I also,
I saw super valuable as like,
you know, meeting all the other
entrepreneurs, all the people interested
in making things right.
So, what better way
than by taking the lead
in the entrepreneurship club
and finding these people,
cultivating these people,
and cultivating an environment
that would be the best place
for entrepreneurship,
like that was my goal.
I just want to make Brown
and a college here
that has Brown and RISD,
the Rhode Island School of Design
as the best place for entrepreneurship.
Yeah, it was like a ton of fun.
I founded
four different conferences there,
like founded like a speaker series
like trips to San Francisco and New York
to visit alumni.
Like so many different things,
like having 10x the group size,
like double the budget
of the entrepreneurship club,
engage an alumni group.
So, we have like an alumni presence
interview a new and found a new direct,
help find a new director for the new
Nelson Center for Entrepreneurship,
help think about the space and etc.
So, I was super involved in that.
And it was an absolutely
super fulfilling experience
and an amazing learning experience,
because I saw it as a platform
to practice entrepreneurship.
And it was just amazing.
And a platform
to practice entrepreneurship, I think,
it reminds me obviously of the program
we both did at MIT launch.
And it's all about
practicing entrepreneurship.
It's taking a sandbox
that you can't really destroy anything,
because the worst thing
that could possibly happen
is that you'll say,
Okay, I tried, I failed.
By the way, I'm still
in high school/college.
And it's not like
I have children to feed
or family to take care of,
and I'll move on
and take the lessons I learned.
So how did that
lead up now to Monthly?
And what are you trying to do
with the education space?
Yeah, so with Monthly,
what we're doing is
we're revolutionizing
how people learn online.
Like this comes from,
like I as a kid,
like always my favorite thing
is learning, right?
Learning and creating things.
So, the question,
I was working on startup,
working on projects,
and then I realized
that I could be working on anything.
Like, I had the resources,
I had the skills.
So, the question that me
and my co-founder, Max,
Max Deutsch ask ourselves was,
what type of life do we want to live?
Right?
And for us, the answer is
we just want to spend time
learning and creating.
Right?
That's what we love.
And so, how can we build a system
that allows us to live this life
and allow other people
to live this life as well.
So, for us, it was like
how do we build
the learning platform of our dreams
and who do we want to learn from?
How do we make it as sociable,
amazing experience?
How do you make it so that you finish
with tangible projects?
So, for our classes, for example,
all our classes,
you finish with something tangible.
So, in our music production class,
you finish with three songs
that you have created
by the end of the month.
In our painting class,
you finish with a realistic portrait
or like a painting that is
inspired by your imagination
and your background.
You can finish with film, etc.
And so, these classes,
they're different from
the normal online classes.
Normal online classes, usually,
there might be just a playlist of videos
that you watch.
But our classes
have a specific start date
and an end date.
All of them are one month,
hence the name, Monthly.
And throughout the experience,
you're put into a peer group
of 20 other students
from around the world.
Right.?
So, you can invite friends
to be in the same peer group,
but you're in the social experience where
you will see what other people
are working on.
You can get feedback,
you receive feedback, you see,
you get inspired, make new friends.
And this peer group
also came from,
at Brown,
I started a group called, [--]
where every Saturday
we would meet at my house
in the living room,
and we would just talk about life
and things that we were learning.
And it was just such an intimate,
amazing environment
and I wanted to replicate that
within Monthly.
So, hence instead of seeing a class
that you have like 2000 students
and you don't really connect with anyone,
we split into peer groups
so you can connect with the 20 peers
that you're learning with.
And by the end of the month,
you get a feedback.
The creator and the instructor
is also interacting with the students.
And then you all finish
with something that you share.
So, everyone finishes with something
that I can't help but share
with all my friends,
family, social media.
And then that just brings in
a lot more people in.
That's amazing.
So, just to understand
a little bit better,
the context of where Monthly,
the market the monthly is in,
so, are these mainly
for young adults or kids
that want to acquire
a new skill, a specialized skill,
that you then provide a month long course
that is very intimate, intensive,
and then by the end of which
they finish with a tangible product?
Is that what you're doing?
Yes.
Our audience is actually, you know,
we've seen people that are
eight year olds to seven year olds,
70 year olds, it's like a huge range
of everyone is interested
because our classes are singing,
music production, art,
even creative engineering and etc.
We have a big range of topics.
But you're right
that the main demographic
is young adults.
Mostly,
they might want to improve their skill,
but also a lot of the times,
they're just,
there in their corporate job
and they want to do something
more with their life.
They want to do something creative,
they want to do something cool,
they want to do something exciting,
or they want to be a part of a community.
And this is
what we're providing to people.
And we see that, you know,
it's transforming people's lives.
People finish the class and they're like,
wow, this has been the most
productive 30 days of my life.
Or I've learned more in this past month
than the past ten years
trying to learn to make music.
And these are quotes
from video testimonials.
At this point, we have thousands
of video testimonials,
people who went out of the way
to record themselves
of how much they love their experience
and posted to YouTube.
And it's just been
super inspirational to see
and to see what people are creating,
the connection that they're making.
And, it's crazy to see that
our completion rates
for people to finish their classes
are 10x the industry averages
for other online platforms.
Really?
Yeah.
Why do you think that is?
What is the factor?
Yeah. I think
it's a combination of factors, right?
So, one,
these classes,
you see the end like
you see what you're working towards.
We frame the classes.
Now this music production class,
you're going to finish with three songs,
right?
And everything in the curriculum
is structured to help you achieve that
and get to that point, right?
So, all the videos,
like the projects, the feedback sessions,
and they all build progressively
towards the final projects.
So, that's one thing.
The other thing is the social aspect.
You're in a peer group
where you see that other people
are submitting the projects,
like watching the video.
So, like monkey see, monkey do.
Like humans are,
like if they see how people doing this,
they don't want to let them down.
Even though they may be strangers,
but they're in your peer group.
They're like, you're going
to get assigned for feedback.
It also helps people.
There's deadlines,
and the deadlines are not just arbitrary.
They're actually, in this case are useful
because if you submit in time
the next day,
you're going to get feedback.
If not, you may not get
because you didn't submit.
So that, then obviously
the classes are framed.
That's like a commitment.
So, it's not just
maybe I'll just like pay
for some subscription service that like
maybe I'll get to this later.
Like it usually never happens.
This is like a month
and you're going to commit
and there's a start date
and a finish date.
So, mentally people are prepared for that
and the prices are also high.
Right?
So, there's various reasons
why we wanted raise the prices high.
One of them is for the commitment.
Like we want people
to actually commit
and follow through
and finish their classes.
So, the classes are priced
around usually $279.
So, people are serious about it
and they enroll and they go for it.
I think that's super, super cool.
Yeah.
and like the instructors that we get,
there are always
big name people who already have
big audiences are very charismatic
in the way that they teach.
So, people are always engaged.
The curriculum that we design
is very much like,
we spend a lot of time
being very meticulous about how we design
a very effective, engaging curriculum.
So, that also helps.
I think it's just like
such a big combination of things.
Well, what surprised you
the most out of the journey?
Or even more interesting than that,
what lessons did you take with you
from your prior
entrepreneurial experiences
that you're saying like,
wow, I'm so glad
that I had these experiences
at Brown and at MIT launch
and as a kid,
that now I've just started saying,
oh, I've seen this,
I've experienced this,
this is how I want to tackle this?
Yeah. I mean, great question.
I think there's just endless
things and ideas
that you can learn from,
even from mistakes,
from successes or anything,
I think you can learn.
I think,
are you looking for like a specific
like nuggets of advice
or like specific experience
that happened?
I'd love to know how you see
your prior entrepreneurial experience
folding into or molding into Monthly?
Because a lot of people are saying,
yeah, I'll defer entrepreneurship
to when I'm good and ready,
I'll accumulate
professional experiences
and then I'll be an entrepreneur.
And here you have an example
of somebody
who's been an entrepreneur
their whole life
leading up to this moment.
Oh, yeah, well, I mean,
I think it's there, like,
I just I see anything that comes up
with Monthly, has come up
like most cases like before.
Or even if they hasn't come up,
you have the muscle and the exercise
of being able to figure new things out.
And a lot of it is like
pattern recognition.
There are a lot of patterns, even though
that might be slightly different.
It's like slightly similar
to other things you've done before.
So, that exercise and practice
of entrepreneurship,
I think is like extremely
valuable and fun and rewarding
and everything that you want
and useful for later on.
I just see it everywhere.
Like, you know,
one thing is with
working with a team and leading people,
I think that was huge when I was
a president at Brown.
Others like how do you figure out,
how do you code an app
and what needs to get built?
For all the apps
that I had before Monthly,
under my time at Brown and before Brown,
I think I had seven
apps in the App Store.
So, I was like very familiar
with the launch process.
And then other learning experiences
was like, you know,
I built something really cool.
But then I realized that
even though the thing was really cool,
it's not going to get to anyone's hands
if there's no distribution.
Right?
So, learning about distribution
and learning about like
not talking to users
and reading between the lines,
I think a lot of times
you may ask a question,
people may say something,
but they're really meaning something else
or they have a deeper
desire or they're trying to satisfy.
So, it's a lot about
building up that intuition
to being able to identify
these things.
I love it.
If you were to ask
what people wanted,
they would have said, faster horses.
Right. Right.
100%.
Valentin, I'm sad that
we only have 20 minutes
for this show, but thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Before we finish, what are three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Good question.
One,
let's say understander.
I love to understand things,
it's like my favorite thing with learning,
thing that I like is understanding.
And so understanding
about the world, about myself,
about people, about concepts, everything.
I just love understanding.
Second one is "differinker".
And this is like a made up word
because basically I just made it up.
It means like "different thinker".
I love to think differently.
I like love to just
go off the beaten path,
like come up with new words,
new ideas, new ways of doing things.
And that's something
that represents that.
And then the third one is
"slow-B", is also made up word,
which means that I love
focusing on slope
more than a Y intercept.
And this comes from a quote
that I love is,
"a little bit of slope
makes up for a lot of y intercept".
Right?
So, Y intercept is,
where you may be right
and that like, if you see two lines,
like I may not have it
be able to draw this,
but usually,
what matters most is the slope.
Even if you started,
there's a line that started up here.
The slope is like this.
If you started down here,
the slope is like this.
It'll cross it in short amount of time.
So, I think as long as you're focusing
on growth and learning,
then you can get to anywhere.
100%.
And I think that
it's even more relevant
when you're thinking,
people often say that,
look, somebody else
is already doing this
or somebody else is starting off
at a different stage than I am.
And it's not about
the stage of starting off.
It's a marathon.
It's not a sprint.
It's about how,
it's about the slope,
the slope of your trajectory,
not about the starting point
that's both takes over
very, very quickly.
Valentin, thank you very, very much.
Enjoy your time
in Los Angeles with Cliff.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
And thank you for being on the show.
Thank you, Michael,
Thank you for hosting.
Take care.